Frane saying they're doing the follow-up
to Jack and Jill is really pretty simple
there's really nowhere to go but up
that's my boy stars Adam Sandler and
Andy Samberg amongst some other people
as well it's a story of a man-child
played by Adam Sandler when he was very
young he had sex with his teacher
spawning a spawn and that spawn turns
into Andy Samberg now Adam Sandler when
he was a kid was really famous because
he was the kid who actually got the
teacher and he pretty much became rich
off that news stories memorabilia a TV
movie but Andy Samberg grew up in that
shadow because he was the baby of the
teacher and the kid and so eventually
when he turned 18 he moved out moved far
away started his own life changed his
name and everything and this movie
reunites them back together on the eve
of his wedding with the chick from The
Roommate that movie oh no I like I
understand that I do I think he's a
funny guy and he always seems like he's
a nice guy whenever I see him in
interviews he always seemed very humble
not affected by the Hollywood Life and I
like that when actors like that and this
movie is of course better than Jack and
Jill and you know honestly I could go in
the bathroom right now and create
something better than Jack and Jim
that's my boy kind of reverts to the
classic Adam Sandler genre that he kind
of invented for himself and when I say
that I mean this he kind of has a bit of
a checklist there are certain things you
need number 1 Adam Sandler has to play a
man-child someone who is an adult but
doesn't really act like an adult you
know he's he's very immature he grew up
thinking can be a certain way perhaps he
was rich or he got famous for some
reason that doesn't really mean anything
but now he's rich and he can be a
man-child and somewhere along the way
something has to be introduced to teach
him a lesson perhaps someone has to
treat like a son or actually he has a
son and now he has to take care of him
also it is absolutely required to have a
sexual subplot involving an elderly
woman or women for some reason that's
got to be in all of them Sandler y also
it's very important for him to at least
have a couple of his personal real-life
friends whose lives he is basically
financing at this point particularly
this man and unfortunately this man Nick
Swardson has a fairly large supporting
role in this movie and I really just
don't like that guy I just don't find
him funny I mean if anyone saw Bucky
Larson and walked out and was like that
was a great one
that was a pretty good movie wasn't it
Tim oh boy I really liked that one I
shoot you in the face also it's very
important for him to have a kind of
high-pitched or childish voice
something like this we're gonna do this
we're gonna do that go it's nice to see
him doing anything really that's not
Jack and Jill but then for the most part
I just didn't laugh that much during
this movie there are definitely funny
times in this movie and there were a few
jokes that work for me but there's only
so many times when I can watch a
500-pound man running around naked and
find it funny and that's zero I didn't
really buy the chemistry between Adam
Sandler and Andy Samberg it felt very
forced it didn't feel natural there are
subplots in the movie that were really
disgusting and I understand that it's
like an r-rated comedy for Adam Sandler
but it just it didn't feel necessary I
didn't really add much humor to the
movie and I wasn't expecting any
sophisticated comedy and I can totally
switch off my brain sometimes and just
laugh at stupid things that are on the
screen if they're funny but I do like it
when it seems like someone's at least
trying to work for humor and I just
didn't buy it in this movie there
weren't that many laughs from me if
you're a fan of Adam saying there's more
Classic Movies you'll probably
appreciate this movie more but for the
most part this is just kinda one of
those movies where you can literally see
like every single place it's going to go
from the start if you've ever watched an
Adam Sandler movie before so I'm gonna
give that to my boy a c-minus like I
said it's not a terrible movie it's
definitely a step up from some of his
more recent comedies so what's your
favorite Adam Sandler movie I mean for
me he has two different types first
comedies I probably see happy gilmore
for his more serious movies I'd say
punch-drunk love what do you guys think
and as always guys if you liked this
review you can subscribe to my channel
and get stuck mine I friggin go
Oh